[Music]  meagan Markel yesterday's on him the  menswear chic and an awards ceremony in  the London yeah an inside she charmed  the Brits even more after coming to the  rescue of a fellow presenter I'm truly  privileged to be here the future royal  was a polished pro at the endeavour fund  awards for injured veterans but her  fellow presenter Neil Heritage had an  Oscar flub moment his papers were all  shuffled up different notes make it  remained poised while helping sort out  the snafu must be her acting training  okay just sit Thank You Dame Helen  Mirren has rave reviews for Megan  the Oscar winner for the queen is now  starring as an heiress living in a  mansion filled with ghosts in Winchester  she thinks megan will fit into her new  royal role as splendidly i think she's  absolutely kind of naturally got what it  takes and i think i think she's a really  wonderful addition to the royal family  and she's very beloved already in  england